Mexico last year's pictures but little
has changed the Miss World composition
promises to bring the world's most
beautiful women on the same stage and in
2019 it's seen size 8 is still the
fashion in fact even though there are
over 110 different countries represented
here at the rehearsal for this year's
event every body shape looks the same
and in an era of body positivity when
products from a shower gels to lingerie
are marketed to all body shapes and
sizes this stage can feel outdated all
these women are being the best versions
of themselves they're healthy women and
that's why it's promoting body
positivity by showing inclusivity the
Miss World competition is one of the
most coveted Beauty titles its roots as
a bikini competition in the 1950s put it
on odds with feminist movements around
the world with accusations of sexism and
objectification but the organization
says it's a platform for women to raise
awareness and funds in aid of
humanitarian causes it points to the
charity work contestants do and sites
millions of dollars being raised every
year through its beauty with a purpose
program the Miss World Organization told
us miss world is an advocate for female
empowerment and provides a platform for
women across the globe to raise
awareness about issues they believe in
Miss World has no rules about weight or
size and promotes body positivism and
self-esteem
aníbal denim heads an organization that
helps women in business she rejects the
idea that Miss World is evolving you
know do I think that their force for
good in the world No do I think that
they're providing good role models to
young girls no and I think that is a
real problem you know a lot of work I do
is around trying to inspire young girls
to become entrepreneurs and I think if
they're looking up to competitors in
this world
pageants then that's less likely than I
would like it to be this year the event
enters
70th year if it was a contestant on
stage it would be deemed far too old but
with millions still tuning in to watch
there could be a long time yet before
the Miss World competition kicks off her
heels and retires sorry a child risque
knees